he gave me a fare interview the other
day so I might as well ask him a
question all right Thank You mr.
president and pick you up there you told
me the other day that you are an open
book
so I think I am an open book so point
blank Democrats go after your tax
returns will you try to block that or
will you allow them now look as I've
told you they're under audit they have
been for a long time they're extremely
complex people wouldn't understand him
it done by among the biggest and best
law firms in the country same thing with
the accounting firms the accountants are
very very large powerful firm from the
standpoint of respect the highly
respected big firm a great law firm or
you would you know it very well
they do these things they put them in
but people don't understand tax returns
now I did do a filing of over a hundred
pages I believe which is in the offices
and when people went and saw that filing
and they saw the magnitude of it they
were very disappointed and they saw the
you know the detail
you'd get far more from that and I guess
we filed that down three times but you
get far more from that that you could
ever get from a tax return but when
you're under audit and I'm on a very
continuous order because there are so
many companies and it is a very big
company far bigger than you would even
understand but it's a it's a great
company but it's big and it's complex
and it's probably feet high it's a very
complex instrument and I think that
people wouldn't understand it but if I
were finished with the audit I would
have an open mind to it I would say that
but I don't want to do it during the
audit and and really no lawyer even from
the other side they say often not always
but when you're under audit you don't
have you don't subject it to that you
get it done and then you release it so
when that happens if that happens I
would certainly have an open mind to it
so that means if the audit is still on
you will not turn over the tax return so
your voice under oh nobody would nobody
turns over a return when it's under
okay thank you yeah go ahead